bundestagswahl 2021 erstwähler partie
seid dabei wenn nach 16 jahren zum
ersten mal jemand anderes als angela
merkel kanzlerin wird ist das überhaupt
erlaubt
eure holte show präsentiert die kleine
geschichte begrüßen parteien wir stellen
euch die sechs parteien vor dies
wahrscheinlich über die fünf prozent
hürde schaffen
5 moment mal jetzt habe hier noch ein
spd glatt verpasst heute die grünen und
die fdp alter vor schönheit zuerst also
die freie demokratische partei fdp
66.000 mitglieder durchschnittsalter 51
frauenanteil um die 22 prozent stehen
für freiheit des einzelnen keine
staatlichen eingriffe den markt mehr
investitionen weniger schulden
steuersenkungen globalisierung freigabe
von marihuana kein überwachungsstaat
freies internet keine frauenquote kein
tempolimit
freiheit klingt ja wohl erst mal geil
die liberale bewegung begann so vor 150
jahren grundidee ist maximaler
individualismus und tiefes misstrauen
gegenüber dem staat und autoritäten an
sich die fdp gibt es seit 1948 hat unser
grundgesetz mitgestaltet und war damals
schon gegen zu viel einfluss der kirche
zb in konfessionsschulen da waren sie
ihrer zeit weit voraus
der erste deutsche bundespräsident
theodor heuss von der fdp
viele von euch waren oder sind noch an
einer theodor heuss schule oder wohnen
in einer theodor-heuss-straße wie bei
der cdu gab es auch in der fdp nach dem
krieg leider noch ein paar sagen wir mal
leicht nationale tendenzen
das könnte auch am randstein tour plakat
sein die fdp-fraktion saß auch
traditionell immer ganz rechts im
parlament das änderte sich erst als die
fdk ich weiß nicht warum sie hatten nie
eine mehrheit im bund aber haben
jahrzehntelang in wechselnden
koalitionen mitregiert erst mit der
union das passt später haben sie sich
immer mehr zur mitte orientiert um mit
beiden großen parteien koalieren zu
können eigentlich ist die hauptaufgabe
der fdp bis heute großen parteien zur
mehrheit zu verhelfen so das war diesmal
eigentlich alles wissenswerte über die
fdp kleiner scherz
nachdem sie es erst mal 13 jahre
fröhlich mit der cdu gemacht hatten
machten sie es von 69 82 mit der spd man
nimmt was man kriegen
walter scheel fdp vorsitzender später
bundespräsident und außenminister der
einzige der in seiner amtszeit ein smash
hit hatte 1973 15 wochen in den single
charts weiter drop gebet das deutsche
rhythmusgefühl und dass uns die ganze
welt beneidet zu der zeit änderten die
liberalen auch ihr grundsatzprogramm
schwerpunkt mehr so auf den sozialen
wandel
es sollte alles unsozialer werden weil
es an jedem einzelnen besser geht oder
so ähnlich und der feind war auch damals
schon die groko mit der großen koalition
schaffen sie den politischen schott aus
dem land jede stimme für die fdp ist
eine stimme gegen die große koalition
könnten sie heute noch so senden
die fdp wurde mit den jahren immer mehr
zur reinen klientelpartei auch apotheker
partei genannt
der markt regelt alles jeder für sich
der starke setzt sich durch wer arm ist
es selber schuld der staat soll sich
raushalten klar
fußballspiel ohne schiri läuft auch
super oder eine autobahn ohne blitzer
das ist meine schwester auch darum wurde
regieren mit der spd quasi unmöglich die
fdp wird immer unsozialer bis sie quasi
es hasst wofür die spd steht 1982
zerbrach die rot gelbe koalition eine
weitere zusammenarbeit ist weder den
sozialdemokratischen bundesminister noch
dem bundeskanzler zuzumuten
die koalition aus spd und fdp ist
beendet helmut kohl wurde kanzler und
die fdp es wünschte mal wieder tabulos
in die nächste regierung eine rein und
raus wie bei bassist dietrich genscher
den schnee noch so ein legendärer
liberaler keiner waren länger deutsche
außenminister 18 jahre und als höhepunkt
seiner karriere spricht er 89 in der
deutschen botschaft in prag zur ddr
flüchtlingen
[Applaus]
hieraus leiten
das natürlich ein super trick einfach
los jubeln damit er den wirklich zu ende
bringen kann
vielleicht wollte gern sagen dass ihre
ausreise unter keinen umständen auch nur
zur diskussion steht oder dass ihre
ausreise immer ein traum bleiben wird
das werden wir jetzt einfach nicht an
von nun an ging's bergab
irgendwie zogen liberale ideen nicht
mehr so bei der wahl 98 holten sie 6,2
prozent und mussten in die opposition
dann verzichteten sie anschneiden leute
in ihrem logo offiziell auf die punkte
zwischen den buchstaben f e und p
das ändert alles ja was war sonst im
programm
gelbes flugzeug selbst fällt
leistung wenn familie blätter gelb
arbeit bauen gelber helm shoppen familie
2009 holt die partei mit guido
westerwelle sensationelle 14,6 prozent
die wähler hatten aber keinen bock mehr
hofft ihre gehirne groko als wirklich
fdp fans zu sein wir wollen jetzt
deutschland mitregieren
heute ist die partei die private one man
show von christian gentner
immerhin brach er mit der tradition
regieren egal mit wem 2017 ließ er die
jamaika koalition platzen mit dem
ungeheuerlichen satz es ist besser nicht
zu regieren als falsch zu regieren
das ist nicht mehr meine fdp dabei sind
liberale grundsätze heute wieder aktuell
datenschutz freies internet die
grundrechte in der korona pandemie alles
klassische fdp themen eben frei ja aber
eben nicht für alle nicht nur für die
die erfolg alle anderen sind faul und
selber schuld oder in den worten ihres
besten spitzenkandidaten rainer brüderle
rot rot grün ist nicht das gelbe vom ei
menschen die hart arbeiten
den darf nur nicht die butter vom brot
nehmen das gelbe vom ei und die butter
vom brot während er sich butter aufs
brot mit also entschuldigung gut
themenwechsel
wir schalten auf die grünen genau oder
korrekt bündnis 90 die grünen heute
wahrscheinlich die klassische erst
wähler partei rund 107000 mitglieder
durchschnittsalter 48 frauenanteil 41
prozent stehen für ökologie
gerechtigkeit umverteilung
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen für alle
erneuerbare energien atomausstieg
kohleausstieg keine massentierhaltung
freigabe von marihuana frauenquote mehr
radfahren tempolimit 130 eine junge
partei aber sowohl um auch nicht mehr
gegründet 1980 hervorgegangen aus
diversen protestbewegungen anti
atomkraft friedensaktivisten sozialisten
frauenbewegung sozial ökologisch
basisdemokratisch und gewaltfrei wollte
man sein und man war grundsätzlich
erstmal dagegen die grünen selbst
bezeichneten sich als
die parteien partei wo habe ich das
später noch mal gehört ich komme ich
drauf und gleich im gründungsjahr
drehten sie den meiner meinung nach
besten weiß pott aller zeiten europa
warum sind die fische tot weil die
industrie das rheinwasser vergiftet die
grünen die arbeiten für eine gesunde
umwelt das sind noch menschen wie du und
ich annegret und die kleine annegret ist
heute cdu verteidigungsministerin schon
drei jahre nach gründung zogen sie mit
5,6 prozent in den bundestag ein
ein wirklich erfrischender anblick in
der pizza bude
jetzt hieß es endgültig in den ersten
jahren fetzten sich zwei parteiflügel
fundis gegen real los also harte radikal
ökos gegen realisten die auch mal
regieren wollen und dafür kompromisse
eingehen jutta ditfurth
gründungsmitglied trat 1991 aus der
partei aus weil ihr das alles nicht mehr
rad korbel noch war aber eher hier
joschka fischer der heute unbedingt wie
viel arroganz ist jetzt schluss und das
ist der erste grüne minister in einer
landesregierung zu 80 in hessen gut nur
umweltminister aber immerhin fischer
trug bei seiner vereidigung ich kann das
gar nicht aussprechen so leicht kann man
damals in die nachrichten
es handelt sich um das modell
fortschritt von nike die schuhe stehen
heute ist kein witz im deutschen
ledermuseum in offenbach
ich weiß das klingt ein bisschen
bescheuert aber ja es gibt ein deutsches
ledermuseum in offenbach
als die mauer fiel interessierte sich
kurz keine sau mehr für umweltschutz und
die grünen scheiterten an der
fünf-prozent-hürde
93 fusionierten sie mit der ostdeutschen
reform partei bündnis 90 seitdem heißen
sie offiziell bündnis 90 die grünen die
partei orientierte sich immer weiter weg
von der alten protestpartei mit erfolg
haben 1998 regiert
sie im bund eine rot grüne koalition
unter gerhard schröder und die grünen
stellt nicht nur ein umwelt sondern auch
eine gesundheitsministerin und den
außenminister
schwer zu sagen ob joschka fischer sich
hier wirklich freut angeblich war in
seinem glas mineralwasser das kann man
bei gerd schröder auf jeden fall
ausschließen
die grünen waren ganz oben angekommen
und zeitz bei der man wissen wir große
macht große verantwortung
1999 schickt deutschland soldaten in den
kosovo krieg für viele in der grünen
basis ein absolutes no go fischer
bekommt beim sonderparteitag dafür einen
farbbeutel an den kopf geschmissen
ich hätte ja nicht so sagen ob die
grünen werden immer unruhiger
sie tragen den massiven sozialabbau die
hartz-reformen und die agenda 2010 mit
hat sie viele wähler gekostet aber
regieren macht spaß
renate künast landwirtschaftsministerin
führt 2001 das biosiegel ein geile sache
das dosenpfand eingeführt von jürgen
trittin 25 cent pro dose damit menschen
die wegen der agenda 2010 in altersarmut
leben sich etwas dazuverdienen können
vielen dank und natürlich winfried
kretschmann erster grüner
ministerpräsident überhaupt die grünen
waren immer eine partei die in umfragen
besser abschneidet als bei wahlen klar
will ich grün sagt man offenbar so wie
ich es kaum fleisch und wenn dann nur
aus dem bioladen oder ich war ganz oft
mit dem fahrrad zur arbeit ja mach ich
wirklich die grünen sitzen in 14 von 16
landtagen
regieren den elf ländern mit sogar in
bayern wollten sie letztens mit der csu
zusammen aber also
der gedanke ist schon lustig das
hauptproblem der grünen mittlerweile
sind alle parteien ein wenig grün machen
ein bisschen klima hier energiewende da
probt fahrradwege dort grüne themen sind
voll mainstream geworden aber das ist ja
wohl auch endlich mal in der fucking
zeit dafür
das war es von grün und gelb
checkt auch unsere anderen folgen also
ich kannte die grünen ja schon als sie
noch cool wan ne na.de es geht ist es
fertig vielen dank fürs einschalten wenn
sie unserer kleinen underdog partner
sendung der heute show auch eine chance
geben wollen können sie diese hier
abonnieren weitere videos finden sie
hier
auf wiedersehen